per questi ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono famiglie io ci sono con
pietro siamo tornati su un naufraghi e
bisogno due visto che l'episodio uno mi
è piaciuto non mi ricordo di aver mai
rischio video di michael con così tante
views su youtube ai ha incastrato a ok
dice che non sappiamo usare le pedate
bei ragazzi siamo all'episodio 2 la cosa
che volevo dirvi è che nell'episodio 1
abbiamo fatto un miliardo e mezzo di
cose quindi va beh ci sono le piante che
che che volteggiano nell'aria ma non lo
so ma guarda che bello il mio cappello
ma perché che per la forma migliore ma
perché sono uniti sono diventate un ip
ma che va bene ma abbiamo preso io ho
dei chiamanti fermi o la cosa perché
lascio dei diamanti nell'inventare
l'aiuto abbiamo 6 diamanti zio alla
scalata facciamoci un po di roba prima
perché abbiamo troppe cose cioè non
possiamo andarci come dei pezzenti
almeno facciamoci le cose innanzitutto
anzitutto no mio penne sto facendo tutto
per me non piace una sega
ok andiamo no spam
beh io sono pronto tu non sei pronto
cazzi tuoi andiamo no aspetta un attimo
mi con uno niente da miglior ferro dami
ferro ed è lì che sta cuocendo e sul 2
per quanto è usato mandiamo amico vieni
sotto vieni sotto la miniera e questo è
ora i massi che l'ultima volta c'era
questa gabbia che non si sa dove porti
anche perché c'è stamira che
incredibilmente grossa più che però se
viene di misteri e io ai misteri
dobbiamo entrare tutti insieme quadrato
ma allora sei stronzo ascom fermati un
attimo non sappiamo che cosa c'é qua
sotto che cosa ci vai a fare diamante
dove svetta buoni prendi loro perché c'è
un sacco di gente brutta però aia agli
ami corna sui diamanti qua pietro biolo
strisce no sono scemo se facevo quanto
la cagata bruttissima tarsu aiuto pieno
aiuto aiuto pietro aiuto vi è proprio
morino morire un primo e pittorica
madonna che male che vale sono a carico
scarico è che questo morto io
praticamente sei morto l'hack è male 26
ma dove sei eccoti ti vedo ti vedo già
con uno scheletro qua lo uccidono ucciso
noti cagare addosso per qualsiasi cosa
prendiamo anti maledizione 3 che su un
book 55 ok ho preso altri tre pezzi a
mantenere gli altri sei in totale
poi c'è della della pietra di kate moss
ci deve essere uno spazio di qualcosa in
teoria non c'è quando c'è uno spazio a
chi cambiandosi nei bambini di tre anni
l'iniqua vieni qui hai un aiuto aiuto al
akhbar
l'ania marianna qua c'è la pietra mossa
o questo di uno spoiler preso questo
podio ci sono sconti scheletri ci sono
sconti che l'high al numero procede
arriva si esce si uccidono alle quanti
purtroppo troppi tagli anche male ok ok
entra gli olo io per loro o per la sei
scemo no mettiamo e torce disattiviamo
ha così si disattiva esatto si sa non
sapevo se ci sono delle una targhetta ci
scriviamo si sa prendila ok per in tutto
quando prendi perfetto se c'è qua c'è
altra roba amico madonna che madonna mi
sono cagato addosso ma tu sei scemo ma
tu sei tu sei una persona che sa che
stavo dicendo 2b dolore ma tu sei
stupido mica mi sono cagate bambini
bambini bambini madonna che male fanno i
bambini propone un cuore mi sa che devi
tornare indietro per inciso treno veloce
veloce veloce per accettare dietro
chiude uditivo di che oggi ho chiuso con
la pietra che l'aquila quella di te non
ho carne da darti ma la cosa non è
niente andiamo avanti
tieni mangiati quest'occhio di ragno
come giorno comunque solido che diranno
però mangiarlo guarda non sapeva hai
appena posso morendo pietro pietro
ma se in testa di merda sa cosa mi
faceva con la roba di reach a male
padano si fa danno all'occhio di cosa
non sapevo solo forte io mamma mia
quanto sono forte gli scatti tutti
dietro c'è lo scheletro sporca di quella
poi lo zombie zombie
mamma mia quanto forti quattro morti
sarà ancora ancora ancora ancora lo
schivo assassin's creed madonna dove
deve essere usciti scusa
non lo so dall'altra trovate durante per
terra occhio madonna che male mi ha
fatto l'ultima sei morto d come piacerà
c'era una strega è una strega di una
strega dietro e torna qui mica ho
trovato altro diamante è andata via la
strega problema non è quando vedi la
strega quando non la vedi più il
brunello eccola la vedo ma è forte se
prova ad ammazzarla bella lascia 42 mi
ha visto mai visto aiuto quanto a kakà e
quelli non è allora che vogliono mai
attaccato attaccato me forte
non lo so tacca la bravo pietro bravo
grazie a 0 6 proprio forte qui c'è un
amante se vogliono quanti diamanti si
trovava dove sono scusate il mio video a
minchia raccolgo io mio nonno a mio
avviso diamante zitto dai più diner già
tanto fa per avere ancora ritmo quanto
se ne sa darmi sito 15 maledizione non
ho mai fatto una caverna con questi
tanti diamanti che sembriamo ma c'è da
incazzarsi sul serio un uomo così altro
rocco quanto è grosso suo posto di sei
uno stranissimo arrivare o dvd
serve un thor c'è anche rigori dove la
mozzarella strano e qui a state
rilasciate erdem ora nissim a qui sono
di moda quindi far fuori me mob che
fuori nuclei per quello occhio occhio ma
sei stupido allora cioè dei problemi
neurali turk suscitarono bobbio ma io
non so non sono smartphone sono studiato
cos'è marina però marina la ragazza di
stefano urso marina marina marina aiuto
questa roba
ti fanno male quelli si beccano così
ogni anni si chiamano i guardiani de che
ma cos'è dragon ball ma [ __ ]
no no fanno male iolo jolo
ma non muoiono
non sanno uno morto per lui è una
squadra fortissima vieni ai verdi questa
sponda vieni qua dettaglia guardalà ci
sono delle cose scritte in inglese
esatto vuol dire vi aspettano tutto io
traduco york spada forte ho tradotto
andiamo andiamo che conquistiamo tutto
qua gli spacco la famiglia ma bastardini
di così sito zitto e uno spoiler di
bianco fermati a ecco perché l'hack è
male ok c'è niente artemista chester non
c'è solo quello c'era praticamente con
il primo valentia mento in fuochi dare
quindi avversari col secondo che ti
danno quindi ce la dovremmo tenere per
quando andremo nel metro beh ma non
penso che c'è questo aspetto aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspettano coprimi
coprimi potrei di vita te l'ho ucciso
devo sparare titolare
bastava stare ammazzano ho messo il
cuore un mezzo cuore ho messo cuore sono
grazie agli aiuti noi dovremo cio che io
non ci credo la spola della spada marina
spada ora cavalca mi sono salvato inizia
soldato insensato e torna subito su
tornei come dorno o troppa roba o
diamanti fortissimo una scuola nava
donna quindi sbuco dal soffitto
maledizione non so neanche quanto siamo
in fondo
no no no no no no no madonna menomare
era era e la l'acqua episodi e ci fosse
grave l'eroe morto questo ora tanto non
so neanche se riesco arrivano in
superficie amico a mykonos essere tra i
vari superfici aiuto arriva aiuto nuovo
co.co.co aiuto ahi ahi ahi a sto
scherzando a parlare ci credo non ci
arrivano ci arriva non ci posso credere
non ci credo mai potrebbe andar peggio
potrebbe piovere ma all'indizione dover
dove sono mora a voi bianchi tutto vero
in consiglio dove sono morto e non lo so
no no voglio trovare quel punto che mi
trovo il punto dove sono morto perché
posso ancora trovarci e la roba è
rimasta libro non vedo fai una roba ma i
beni sotto e torna in quel punto di mila
e coordinata
mi chiamo dato oramai raga 723 hicks 24
y e 60 z mai non vedo niente di sotto
come faccio io sto raccogliendo è hai
trovato la roba allora presente centrica
che tu con le torce
sì ce l'ho con le torce a respiri dove
sei più di tutto ma non prevedono da
dove sei
ecco il tt vedo quanto mi vedi se la
luce si la luce è un punto per entrare
tranche per entrare gli può respirare
dentro negli abissi maledizione o mio
dio sono molto qua ipsi morto qui entra
nella bolla la scuola preso o la spada
ma pensa te dio mio vanto quanto verso
la roba a lo ha fatto a spargersi così
tanto è perché è esplosa aia sto morendo
anche evocativa quindi cosa ma cosa ma
qua spostati
ok ma che faccia perdurerà per le palle
basta c'è tutto no altro che tutto per
un bottino ancora i diamanti oro o
diamanti 16 e o la spada bene allora
abbiamo tutto praticamente non abbiamo
solo questo è anche a trova tra rotula
vediamo andiamo andiamo andiamo andiamo
e mari non c'è riuscita sopra 10 arrivo
io ci arrivo perché io credo nel cuore
delle carte ce la faccio ce la faccio io
ce la faccio ce l'ho fatta sono salite
eccoci mirati e magari un film di
hollywood
brutta roba basta c'è orribile basta non
facciamo di spedizioni così avventate
metti tutto nella cesta che basta che
crescano le piante nell'aria 20 20 22
diamanti in totale guardo attaccature
piacere piegata possiamo pescare cioè la
mia terra non si può 5 stream e bene
allora dov'è la roba baia per le opere
legno mio pesco no io pascoe canna da
pesca
allora che che pesce voi stasera e lo
mangino ma io so che pesce come si sa le
qua
mandai pesco dall'albero ma come bestie
ma sei scemo eh beh come bestie dalla
riva nella prima serie di naufraghi o
pescava dall'albero quindi tu non sai
non rompere le balle che è bella la
tranquillità e bellissima so perché non
siamo riusciti a prendere tutte che
siamo tranquilli adesso meno male poi
torneremo di sotto per completare la
spedizione per adesso va bene così
tregua
eccolo un salmone facciamo travis
facciamo il sashimi sashimi di sushi
nicolini di reeves al morbo lo cucino io
ragazzi ma e olio che mixa pescata
qualcosa inseguimento e tranquillo
dunque il luminol e quindi tolio finite
perché pesco io tanto ne hai fatto che
321 trota è un libro di merda come ho
fatto a pescare un libro ma io posso
mangiarmi il libro click di 20 pt di
gente adesso il loonie comincia a
mangiarla che da servono va qualcuno
bagni questo ragazze fra i poteri non
c'è anche la chat maledizione quindi io
voglio mangiare questo vi dal libro di
letteratura delle medie cosa hai portato
da mangiare lorenzo è pascoli d'annunzio
a e dopo una bellissima spedizione una
giornata così se niente è ora di cenare
per me per pietro tieni pietro questa la
tua cena e mentre mangiamo abbiamo anche
l'onore di parlare di quello che ci sta
succedendo noi ci siamo ritrovati da
soli nell'oceano come due amici quindi
quello che ti voglio dire è che
innanzitutto non dobbiamo mangiare come
dei mongolo edicola schiena curva non
c'è bisogno paoli della presa la seconda
cosa è che come mangiare come allietare
il nostro appetito
se non con le poesie di d'annunzio la
preghiera prima di mangiare la preghiera
ok tirava il pesce tiravo di pesce nome
nobel brescia l'altro pilota ok ecco
perché quel pesce di preghiera prima di
mangiare money money così ma nikos mani
amen sono sei capace mariam e non si
rende giustizia a niente a me lo faccio
io per pietro grazie signore che ci hai
dato il pesce che ha pescato valigia e
quindi grazie fa vj per il pesce
grazie signore che nella spedizione ci
hai fatto trovare un sacco di diamanti
napoli l'ho trovato io quindi grazie ai
famigliari non si mangia c'è la
preghiera prima a zitto grazie signore
che siamo finiti sull'isola deserta
vabbè mangiamo vuoi dormire la notte
allora prima di dormire prima che sia
notte buonanotte vorrei ringraziarti per
questa compagnia e quindi volevo dirti
una cosa molto importante prima di
addormentarci contorno oggi è una è una
nuova giornata
buongiorno hanno fatto le uova in questi
questi maledetti sporcaccioni quella
quanto sono scovato in tutto sto periodo
e sono usciti 20 non è uscito niente non
è uscito niente a mykonos peccati tutte
4 dopo che abbiamo recuperato un po di
legno degli alberi circostanti piazza
suckling e andiamo a concludere quello
che era il nostro giro di prima perché
sembra invece ancora voi cosa da
guardare alle fasi concludiamo da 100
per cento la caverna e poi passiamo alle
cose un po più strong come potete vedere
ci sono dei cartelli attorno alla nostra
isola che segnano delle posizioni di
danger misteriosi che non abbiamo torre
sprona quindi dopo la caverna di a
vedere questi dungeon assurdi che non
promette bene questa avventura visto che
siamo tutti e due molto competenti
cogliere un gioco magico e vedere cosa
c'è è fatto accendino di archeo la cia
media ma tu sei stupido maggio si
stupido ma si butta no no no no fermo
piedi ma sei pazzo t'ammazzo mitigato la
roba ma se in piromani schifoso molla ce
n'è anche il pvp una graziosa ma in un
luogo csen hai un altro deed of war 40
maledizione ci manca solo che dai fuoco
alla casa porco ha fatto venire una se
credibile te lo giuro ma i pirla
scendiamo prima di fare cagate 6 quando
vedevo dio variata la donazione nel
lazio fu halloween
cosa dico meno soldi non c'è un marito
following distrib
se sentite a taranto è arrivato un
following a caso iscrivetevi al canale
chi si iscrive al canale appare quella
roba lì è un diamante hai lasciato guido
saldi è un diamante
ho lasciato sono certo io sono tutto
orbo sono amici amanti e vabbè quanto
riconosciuta lasciatevi amanti in via de
cecco s.nicola che lo abbiam perso prima
io se non c'è colo e tu sei ecco come
sarei tanto ammazzo io arrivo subito a
marzo che vedevo che di girare per
cercarne le basi ritardare o mio dio
questo scassato
ho trovato una cesta completamente a
caso scassando soffitto ho trovato una
cesta te lo giuro veloce dentro
non lo so sembra uno spot jones fondi di
zombie non so come ho fatto ad arrivarci
c'è un elmetto di diamante dentro cos'è
sta roba
non lo so non ho idea i toni da eco per
favore uno stop allo spacco nome di
sztum nord est ce ne sono due ce ne sono
due
quanti sono aiuto aiuto pietro addio
[Musica]
daje popolo dai e fuoco e gilda cerino è
il momento di fare piromane cos'è sta
roba spacca perché gli ha messo le torce
intorno 20 e dolce mentre se io ok ok
cos'è sta roba non lo so c'è un tunnel
c'è un tunnel che storia che casino che
sei questa 5 madonna mentre scorrono in
un'auto stoner proprio oppure scusa di
cosa è decisamente un rompi lo c'è
un'altra festa un'altra città elia
rimbalza destra la vedova qua ma quanta
gente aias quella mina si capisce quindi
le pietre strane anno fisi vertici
madonna quanti zombie aspetta però fa
riferire ok sono dentro ma a maglia
l'amore è più o meno da sola era più
difficile ho tratto due porzioni più 130
tech ma è dalle città tristan tiene
istante vita c'è un buco ma sotto
ovviamente andarci si sono entrato gesù
c'è un altro buco sono entrato in un
altro buco c'è una cesta ha trovato due
occhi di vender e due le scale sono
entrato non ha idea di che giro ho fatto
per entrare dentro un casino che
continua su un'altra certo qui c'è
dentro controlla vediamo altri due uova
sfondi di piccole piccole pecore e si
eccitano aveva prima ancora quando
ancora ok bene arrivando dal corridoio
del corridoio ma che poi su ok vai
quanto profonda quasi un altro sport
nello spacco previsto l'inizio
no meglio che può metterlo tonio perché
ce ne sono pochissimi anche perfetto c'è
acqua o mio dio allagato tutto scusa
pietro fatto una cagata spacca il
soffitto spacca soffitto
eccolo li guardava vj cosa ti va a genio
sherlock holmes chi scusa
dispone rider è uno sprone a c'è gente
basta aver ammazzato ricarica date 12
perfetto mai cosa c'è dentro niente una
stanza che trasuda acqua non c'è new
york a vacca appena riusciamo usciamo
show emma vissuto personale ss2 sono
uscito pietro sono fuori ce l'ho fatta a
eccoti mamma mia no io un ora che sto
peste lo giura un'ora perché hai fatto
un pene gigante sul tempo è stato fatto
inizio di questa cosa in satin comunque
allora prima di concludere vorrei dirvi
che dalla prossima volta andremo a
esplorare p d'angelo che abbiamo intorno
che non avevo ancora visto questi qua
sono qua che ci guardano da un sacco di
tempo e non li abbiamo ancora neanche
toccati perché volevamo prima esplorare
la caverna principale cosa che abbiamo
già fatto quindi appena inizia la croce
pisodio andremo esplorare i dungeon di
fianco sicuro perché li vedo cazzuti e
ogni amico di fare una cosa
importantissima di fare 10 in palazzi
per le pecore
prima di concludere rado ma una nera
razzismo su pecore ragazzine concludiamo
qui l'episodio come ho già detto andremo
negli altri dungeon nel prossimo perché
abbiamo estratto tutta la caverna
principale tutta quanta e abbiamo anche
esplorato il mini danno che abbia
trovato all'interno che non ci
aspettavamo assolutamente di trovare
quindi direi che possiamo continuare il
prossimo episodio è stato fighissimo per
adesso la caverna può considerarsi
completata e io la richiudo perché è
fatto quindi chiedo con bene non ho
abbastanza recenti per richiuderla
richiuderla fiat bravo bravissimo e
bellissimo bene bensì che siamo
artistici quindi ragazzi che mi sia
piaciuto cosa semplice
mi piace anche per social come
descrizione ciò che si vede che ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo visto bergamo
[Musica]